what does lcm actually mean
it's simple it's the least common
multiple
but what is the least common multiple of
numbers
some of you may already know how we can
find the least common multiple of
numbers
but do we know what it actually means
let us try to understand the three words
individually
least common and multiple
we go backwards
what is a multiple of a number
let's say we want to find the lcm of 15
and 20.
let me explain what multiples mean
fifteen multiplied by one equals fifteen
so fifteen is one of the multiples of
fifteen
fifteen multiplied by two equals thirty
thirty is also one of the multiples of
fifteen
fifteen multiplied by three equals forty
five
which is also a multiple of fifteen
remember a number has infinite multiples
let us write down the first eight
multiples of fifteen
fifteen times four is sixty
fifteen times five is seventy-five
fifteen times six is ninety
fifteen times seven is one hundred and
five and fifteen times eight is one
hundred and twenty
these are the first eight multiples of
fifteen
similarly let us write down the first
eight multiples of the second number
which is twenty
so these eight numbers here
20 40 60 and so on are the multiples of
20.
so now we know what multiple means
what does common mean
we look for common multiples of the
number
we can see that 60 is present in both
even 120 is present in both
60 and 120 are two of the many common
multiples of 15 and 20.
so now we know what common multiples are
now we get to the first word which is
least
so out of all the common multiples we
choose the one which is least
it's simple
60 is the least common multiple
so the lcm of 15 and 20 is 60.
this was shown just to clear your
concept of lcm
but is this the way we calculate the lcm
of numbers
no it isn't
because when large numbers are involved
it is difficult to find the multiples of
each and then find the least common
multiple
next we will look at different ways in
which we can solve for the lcm of
numbers
you